in this set of videos we will be looking
at the volume and surface areas of
various shapes and
figures the good thing is that we need
to understand just two things volume and
surface area first let's look at what
surface area
means we all know how a rectangle looks
like something like this there are two
things that define a
rectangle its length and its breadth so
what is its surface area it's simple it
is the area of the surface it covers its
area is defined as its length multiplied
by its breadth a special case of a
rectangle is a square it's a rectangle
which has its length equal to its
breadth let's say both the length as
well as its breadth equal s
units its area will equal s * s which is
s squ
units if you already haven't make sure
you see our videos based on perimeter
and area where we have shown how these
formula are
derived anyway why did we need to know
this now look at this three-dimensional
box how do we find its surface
area the surface area of a shape is the
area its surface
covers if you look carefully you will
see that it is covered by six
rectangular
surfaces one on top one at the bottom
one in the front and one at the back one
on the left and one on the
right so this figure's surface area will
be the sum of areas of the six
rectangles the three-dimensional shape
we saw is called a cuboid it's a
three-dimensional shape bounded by
rectangular
faces but wait what is its volume then
simply put it is the amount of space it
occupies another way of looking at it is
the amount of space contained within the
shape when do we need to know its
surface area and when would we need its
volume look at it like this if I ask you
to paint this box you would need its
surface area to find out how much paint
you need and if I ask you how much water
this box can store you would need to
know its
[Music]
volume